[Music]
here inside this refrigerator
at a temperature just a tick above
absolute zero
isolated from the rest of the universe
is a quantum computer
if you believe the hype this nascent
technology embodies the promise of the
future
and has the potential to revolutionize
our lives with its turbocharged
computation
but quantum computers aren't the next
generation of supercomputers
they're something else entirely and
before we can even begin to talk about
their potential applications
we need to understand the fundamental
physics that drives the theory
of quantum computing we'll need to dive
into another dimension
smaller and more alien than anything we
intuitively understand
the subatomic world of quantum mechanics
in the 1980s one of the most important
physicists of the 20th century
encountered a major roadblock richard
feynman was hungry for a window into the
quantum universe
but quantum systems by nature are
fragile
and the information they hold hides from
us
because feynman couldn't directly
observe quantum events
he wanted to design a simulation it
quickly became clear that his computer
wasn't up to the task
as he added particles to the quantum
systems he was modeling
the cost of computation began to rise
exponentially
feynman concluded that classical
computers just can't scale up fast
enough
to keep pace with the growing complexity
of quantum calculations
then he had a breakthrough what if he
could design a tool
made up of quantum elements itself this
instrument would operate according to
the laws of quantum physics
making it the perfect way to probe the
mysteries of the quantum realm
the idea of the quantum computer was
born
and by dreaming it up feynman had
started to build a bridge between
quantum physics
and computer science to understand how
quantum computing works
it's essential to start by understanding
what makes a quantum in the first place
this means that we need to talk about
what's at the heart of quantum physics
a concept called amplitudes quantum
mechanics
at its core is a change to the rules of
probability
and this is also where the power of
quantum computing comes from
from this different from these different
rules of probability
than the ones that we are used to for
example
if you want to know the classical
probability of an event
say a coin landing tails exactly 10
times out of 20
you add up the probabilities of all the
different ways that event could happen
that's just common sense but common
sense doesn't govern the quantum
universe
before you measure a subatomic particle
you can think about it as a wave of
probability
that exists in a kind of black box a
quantum system with many different
chances
of being in many different places
[Music]
amplitudes are closely related to
probabilities
but they're not probabilities a key
difference
is well probability is always a number
from zero to one
amplitudes are complex numbers and what
this means is that they obey different
rules
if i want to know the total amplitude
for something to happen
i have to add up the amplitudes for all
the different ways that it could have
happened
but when i add up amplitudes i see
something new
which is that a particle might reach a
certain place
one way with a positive amplitude and
another way with a negative amplitude
and if that happens then those two
amplitudes
can cancel each other out so that the
total amplitude would be zero
and that would mean that that thing
would never happen at all
this is sort of the central thing that
quantum mechanics says about the world
right that the way that you describe a
physical system
is by a list of amplitudes and the way
that a physical system
changes over time is by a linear
transformation
of these amplitudes but how can quantum
computers use amplitudes
to store and manipulate information
quantumly
this is a qubit it's the basic
computational unit in quantum computing
qubits are like bits in a classical
computer but with a crucial difference
a bit is binary it stores information in
strings of binary digits that can only
be zero
or one but qubits are made of subatomic
particles so they operate according to
subatomic logic
qubits can be zero one or what we call a
linear combination of zero
and one this fluid combination of
amplitudes is at the core of quantum
computing
before you measure a qubit it exists in
a state called superposition
you can think about it as a quantum
version of a probability distribution
where each qubit has some amplitude for
being zero and some amplitude
for being one superposition is the
reason why it takes a vast number of
classical bits to describe the quantum
state of even a tiny number of particles
when two or more qubits are in this
closed state of superposition
they relate to one another through the
phenomenon of entanglement
this means that their final outcomes
when we measure them are mathematically
related
the key concept for understanding how
quantum computing
can be powerful compared to classical
computing
is what we call quantum entanglement and
that is the word we use for the
characteristic correlations
among parts of a quantum system which
are
different from the correlations that we
normally
encounter in the classical world in
ordinary
experience you could think of it as like
a book
when you look at the pages one at a time
you don't see any information you just
see random gibberish
it's because the information isn't
encoded in the individual pages
but in the correlations among them and
to read the book you have to
collectively observe
many pages at once it turns out and this
is part of what's so interesting that if
you want to
describe very highly entangled states
using ordinary bits it's extremely
expensive imagine that you had a
primitive 10-qubit computer
it could store 2 to the 10th power
values in parallel
to describe this entangled configuration
with a classical computer
you'd need 2 kilobytes or 16 000 bits
expand to a system with 500 entangled
qubits
and you now require more classical bits
than there are atoms in the known
universe
this is exactly what feynman meant when
he said that classical computers weren't
scalable for simulating quantum
mechanics
for a quantum computer to be of any use
you need to measure information from the
qubits to get an output
the problem is when a quantum system is
measured
it collapses into a classical state if
anything
carries away information about whether
that qubit is zero or one
so for example if that information gets
recorded in
some radiation that's escaping from the
quantum computer
then the effect on the qubit will be
exactly
as if someone had measured it to extract
an answer from the quantum system that
isn't just a random outcome of
probability
like the flip of a coin we have to use
interference
you can see interference when waves in a
pool
hit each other and one wave is above the
surface and the other wave is below the
surface
and they hit each other and they cancel
each other interference
is just what amplitudes do when you add
them up
if something can happen one way with an
amplitude of a half and another way with
an amplitude of minus a half
then the total amplitude for it to
happen would be zero
this is what you do in the famous double
slit experiment you
close one of the paths and then you see
that now the thing that previously never
happened
now can happen this is a quantum
algorithm
scientists can harness interference by
creating a deterministic sequence of
qubit gates
these cubic gates cause the amplitudes
to add up constructively
this means that they're mathematically
guaranteed to boost the probability
of seeing one of the right answers
you might ask how could you possibly
concentrate all this amplitude
on the right answer when you yourself
don't know in advance
which answer is the right one well you
know this is exactly why
designing quantum algorithms is so
difficult and why
you know we have a whole field that's
been studying it for decades
since 1994 there have been a few major
breakthroughs in quantum algorithms
with theoretical applications in fields
such as cyber
security and search optimization but
according to most
experts in the field quantum computers
are most likely to be useful for what
they were born to do
when a curious physicist wondered about
the deep structure of our world
i find quantum computing exciting as a
way to explore
physics now whether that's going to make
anybody any money
whether there will be practical
applications in the near term that's
still very much an open question
but at least for physicists it's an
exciting time
the truth is the most important
application i believe of quantum
computers is something that we don't
know
yet i'm sure that once we have a quantum
computer to play with
we will find amazing applications that
we can't yet foresee
[Music]
you